okay so listen we're this next story not
something that I already suspected I
wouldn't even be bringing it up but as
many of you know I have long suspected
that Donald Trump from my completely
amateur unsophisticated point of view
sometimes seems to be on uppers and
sometimes seems to be clearly coming
down from uppers there are pictures now
which appear to show boxes and boxes of
sudafed and upper at Donald Trump's desk
we're going to get to all of the details
there is the upper Trump I've mentioned
before that's the one that is speaking
quickly sweating often sniffing a lot
and then there's the other Trump the
slow slurring god bless the United
States of America the depressed looking
and sounding Trump and it's all very
weird and this goes back to that bizarre
tweet that Donald Trump sent during his
2016 campaign where he proclaimed that
he loves Hispanics while eating a taco
bowl from the Trump Tower Grill remember
this tweet and picture happy Cinco de
Mayo the best taco bowls are made in
Trump Tower Grill I love Hispanics and
the really fascinating thing here is not
actually Trump's taco Bowl but it's
what's in the drawer just to Donald
Trump's left and behind him over his
left shoulder short sort of there's an
open drawer which Twitter user Jay
railing points out is filled with boxes
of sudafed quote in 2016
Trump posted a photo of himself that gay
will gave away more than he intended an
open desk drawer revealed box after box
of sudafed piled on top of one another
and when you look closely at that
picture you do see what looked like at
least four boxes of sudafed now Jay
railing makes a few other claims in his
tweet thread I've tried to research them
and they are even more interesting the
first one for example is that although
the photo was taken in New York the
boxes include a type that is only sold
in the UK with a different box and
distinctive ingredients not
in the US I went on cbs.com and indeed
that version of sudafed is not sold in
the United States currently they sell
others but not that one same thing at
Walgreens so it seems that at least
currently this sudafed is not even
available in the United States now as we
know Trump often seems overly alert and
has notably dilated pupils to symptoms
of taking exactly this now the thing is
this is not a new allegation no casler
is a new york city comedian who worked
on trump's show The Apprentice and has
said many times
Trump was snorting adderall and eating
sudafed quote Trump snorted adderall all
through the day on apprentice he also
ate UK sudafed like candy but at night
and at parties he switched to cocaine
and high end methamphetamine that was
hand-delivered by bikers the point is he
was always high
that hasn't changed and of course if you
go back to the video of Trump's debates
with Hillary Clinton there was that
constant sniffing that also raised
questions about Trump's drug use
remember this
[Music]
so that's difficult to listen to I
apologize I'm just being thorough here
and again often extremely dilated pupils
that just don't seem to make sense for
the amount of light that is in the room
where the pictures are often taken so am
i saying this to make fun of Trump no he
may well have a problem but it is to
point out that upper Trump and downer
Trump have been visibly very different
from the beginning and I can only
imagine that if someone has access to
nuclear weapons and is involved in
diplomatic conversations with world
leaders at the highest level this is not
what you want you don't want upper and
downer version of the world leader that
can launch nuclear weapons make or break
alliances and relationships slap tariffs
that destroy you know hundreds of
thousands of workers businesses this is
not a guy that's not a position rather
where you want a guy that has an upper
version and a downer version I want to
hear from you about this what do you
make of this when I've brought up the
Trump up or down or stuff in the past I
get substance abuse professionals who
email me and they say David don't use my
name I it would not be appropriate for
my name to be publicly attached to this
but I've been noticing the exact same
thing as you and I think you're exactly
spot-on let me know what you think about
this the pictures the sniffing the
dilated pupils the entire thing I do
want to hear from you about it